some breaking news to renew concerning a
Harry and Megan and a date has been set
for them to step back officially from
royal duties and that date is the 31st
of March the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
will officially step back from royal
duties from the 31st of March according
to a spokesman for the couple they are
currently in their so-called transition
period during which the the details of
how it might work are being thrashed out
we have been led to believe today or
they're not confirm by Buckingham Palace
that they are to lose the right to use
royal in their title Sussex royal their
website and their Instagram account the
date has been set for it all to take
place all of those changes to come into
effect and that is the 31st of March
let's get more on this now and bring in
our royal correspondent Rhiannon Mills
hello Rhiannon so end of March and
they're out that's right so of course
what it was it a few weeks ago now we
were told that all of the members the
royal family had come together they'd
had that meeting in San jingim and they
had agreed that yes Harry and Megan
could embark on this new path this new
independent life that they wanted away
from royal duties but there was still a
number of different issues that we were
still waiting for answers on so for
example they said back then that this
would all start in spring 2020 as you
said we now have a definitive date for
that it says this will all take effect
on the 31st of March also confirming
something that they told us back then as
well that the Sussex is have agreed to
an initial 12-month review to ensure
that the arrangements work for all
parties
basically because there's no precedent
for this kind of new working model also
because of the fact that they are
stepping away from royal duties and
they'll no longer be undertaking
official engagements in support of the
Queen or being funded by the sovereign
grant it means they'll no longer have an
office within Buckingham Palace last
week it was revealed that a number of
members of staff were being made
redundant
so it means that from the first of April
they'll be represented through their UK
foundation team of course there's still
that big discussion about what exactly
is this new foundation going to be
called we've been talking about that
throughout the day the fact that maybe
they've been told by the Queen that they
can no longer be Sussex royal that the
Royal has to come out of their brand
because they're no longer going to be
working Royals a couple of other things
that I think it's worth pointing out it
what's quite a long email of updates
that we've had in relation to Prince
Harry's honorary military titles he's
going to retain the ranks of Major
leftenant commander and squadron leader
however during the 12-month period this
transition period the Jukes
honorary military positions will not be
used now I think that was one of the
things that certainly upset Prince Harry
because he wanted to be able to continue
those military positions and also does
tie in with the fact that Prince Andrew
also he announced he was stepping back
from public duties but is also retaining
his military positions we also now have
a time frame of the last engagements
really that Harry and Megan are going to
carry out as working Royals they start
with an engagement on the 28th of
February where Prince Harry is going to
drop into a recording session alongside
some Invictus games competitors there's
then a number of other engagements and
it culminates in the 9th of March which
is the Commonwealth service where they
will join the Queen and other members of
the family for that Commonwealth service
at Westminster Abbey so that would be
the first time that we see Harry and
Megan publicly alongside other members
of the family so certainly the optics
around that will be fascinating but also
they have guided within this email that
yes while Harry and Megan at the moment
are over in Canada the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex will be here in the United
Kingdom regularly so there we go some
updates on a Harry and Megan's future as
they transition into this new role that
they have so desperately wanted yeah and
given that we've got this date and these
details being released today does that
mean that all of the details are
thrashed out now Rhiannon or is there
still a lot
to agree I think for me what is
fascinating is within this yes they talk
about the spring 2020 transition taking
effect on the 31st of March but also it
goes on to say there is no precedent for
this new model of working and eventual
financial independence so we are still
going to have that initial 12-month
review to see whether this is working on
both sides of course a few weeks ago we
had the Queen very much saying she
wanted answers on this and she wanted
them fast and then we had that statement
saying yes we've all come to this
agreement it was then a couple of days
later that Prince Harry in front of a
friendly audience at his centre Bally
charity dinner basically made it clear
that he wasn't entirely happy with how
things had played out saying he still
wanted to represent the Queen he still
wanted to do that work across
Commonwealth so I think there are still
things that need to be ironed out and of
course as I've been talking about right
throughout the day one of the big things
is that Sussex royal brand how on earth
do they try and go out into the world
and make money without it being seen
that they are trying to draw and make
money off being members of the royal
family one thing also I didn't mention
earlier is it has been confirmed that
while they're not going to use their HRH
Styles they will still be retaining
those and they'll continue to be known
as the Duke and Duchess of Sussex there
was a little bit of confusion when it
was announced this new kind of working
partnership this new working way forward
what exactly they were going to be known
as with a few problems with maybe a
common being in the wrong place and
Megan being styled as a divorced woman
so now the titles are being confirmed
that they will still be known as a duke
and duchess of sussex but i think going
forward they will still be judged yes
they're not going to be working Royals
but they are still members of the family
and as the Queen in all her statements
that mate has made clear they are valued
members of the family so they will
continue to be judged on that benchmark
and it was Prince Harry who in his
statement said that he will still want
to uphold the values of Her Majesty the
Queen so as we go forward everything
they do will be a judged on that okay
Ronan thank you